une fois que vous êtes installé, laissez-moi voir le
développeur seba cool pour le meilleur pathan
vous pensez que votre monde est sûr c'est une
illusion profitez de ces derniers moments de
paix la tentative était d'essayer d'
aborder cela du point de vue de
quelqu'un qui ne le fait pas  t nécessairement besoin de
savoir quoi que ce soit sur ces personnages ou sur
ce monde, le but était vraiment de
raconter une histoire qui a pris l'origine,
puis et l'a poussée plus loin, un peu comme
le chapitre suivant vos commandants ont
commis un crime que je ne peux pardonner à aucun
d'entre vous  disant
que j'ai attiré votre attention maintenant quand
j'étais enfant j'adorais les tours de magie ce qui est
particulièrement amusant de faire un film comme celui-ci
c'est de travailler avec toute une équipe de vrais
adultes et vous jouez tous
ensemble en faisant la même chose donc  allons-
nous commencer Benedict est un
gars incroyablement travailleur qui prend ce qu'il fait très
très au sérieux, il était juste très
concentré et ces gars étaient si à l'
aise parce qu'ils travaillaient ensemble
sur l'autre film qu'ils étaient
ju  st un peu comme très confortable traîner
et faire leur travail, mais Ben s'est
présenté, il serait comme vous savez que je suis ici pour
travailler l'obtenir et donc tous les autres acteurs
sont comme oh où nous sommes pour
mieux tout
wow c'est le seul sous-marin leurs jeux
immersifs semblent vrais preuves d'innovation juste
sur cette super immunité toujours [ __ ] de
mêlée à Stockholm bienvenue pour dessiner des
bombes d'humidité sont sur les éléphants est
anniversaire kya super citoyen FEMA
paisible Judée une fois zambra plus